okay so what you're trying to do is
you're learning tessabaki but you it's
you can't do the testibility if you
don't feel
where your tandem is in the movement
okay so we just started with a chest
push okay she chest pushes and I'm gonna
go she pushes I'm gonna go into the
center here
I'll have to go in the center then then
she can feel it okay so you're you're
not trying to do the sneaking stuff so
uh from the beginning you're
capturing descent okay
so now I do the chest push you're going
to capture my Center turn your hand
again I want one more rotation
and so what I'm going to do is that's
free my Center
and go back into her
okay so do one hand at a time
this hand is going there don't don't
pivot around your elbow but if you come
around don't step in your arms spiral
spiral let it push on you there you go
okay so there's that arm she's gonna get
my Center so I'm going to move over this
way
she's going to snake around
I'm gonna snake around here you see this
is another in respect
back
if you go here in respiratory you see my
time
and it comes back out capture
[Music]
I'm not going to Pivot around my elbows
okay I just do this that's all I ever do
okay so she's going to inward spiral
turn and I'm going to inward spiral here
so feel your tension right there and I
go around
chest push
around
all right
and on the other hand
oh she's got
here
oh push
yeah I come around here
just come around on the inside again
yeah
one here this way this way okay camera
spirals Counting
oh inward spiral inward spiral Center